good morning John squeezing strangers
bikes in Amsterdam oh yeah yeah look at
that fight
now it's pretty squishy is it okay to
touch random people's bikes you want to
hear a funny story I love my computer on
an airplane so I'm having other people
edit this vlog for me here's the plan I
put this footage on the Internet
people on the internet then take that
footage everybody makes their own video
with it and then we vote on which one
goes on the vlog of the skin and we do
this all within like 24 hours our
Amsterdam things I need I need to find I
mean you see like row house bicycle errs
which shouldn't be hard a canal to come
by Ziggler
nothing to be arranged don't you just
get a feel like you need some kind of
day there's a questionable strategy I'm
a witch just start walking and see if I
find something good I am immediately
lost this city is not on a grid and also
my phone does in 100% work like I can
call it a text but it cannot use maps
there's no data we get real awesome
gonna have to work it out the
old-fashioned way would you do I have
completely forgotten how to jog
[Music]
I mean even the littering is neat that
it's left of their right side up what is
a choco mouth it smells like chocolate
is it like Yahoo well I was going to
read the label but it's all in Dutch
sometimes you think you things on the
ground you don't know what they are
I have to find out oh it's like a little
light like a the tiniest cheapest bike
light you could possibly imagine
you know I'm keeping it
I mean presently without comment pigeon
there's a hole tortilla ollie on a
windowsill right over there hole
tortilla and good feed your entire
family for a month a whole tortilla stop
walking away from me - I'm trying to
help round row houses looks a little
hooks that they used to get stuff up
because they can't can't carry them up
with her to uni all that's left is a
canal I have to find a canal I just saw
fourth Amsterdam thing - people just
smoke pot on the street which of course
normal here I think this is a wedding
cake made out of diapers that doesn't
fight you yep yep I definitely go in the
wrong direction but just ahead of the
highway just just in front of it I think
it's a canal it's a big one a Moorhen
and you see it oh it just disappeared by
Margot come back make it a video hello
it was like I don't we don't like to be
out there it is hey John the Dutch
people think that I'm weird but that's
okay I think the Dutch people are weird
you know this might this might not be a
canal that might be a river it might be
the river Amstel I feel like maybe maybe
not I don't know I have come to the
definitive conclusion that I'm not in
the Canali part of Amsterdam okay John
I'm 90% sure this is the same canal I
was at before I am now a hundred percent
sure that it is in fact a canal which
means I found all the things that I was
looking for so now I have to try and
find my way back to where I was I don't
even know what hotel look this is the
she really take all the cars in
Amsterdam every single Amsterdam Park
the pigeon didn't listen to me I see
these bikes and I I just I think many of
them must have just been here for
centuries I feel like they're
intentionally leaving old bikes just so
it looks like there are a lot of bikers
it got it'd be a lot of these bikes not
in use like like this this one that this
is just still here right like somebody's
left it there or do ya
I'm very glad to finally be in this city
which I've wanted to go to for a long
time and to be here for VidCon Europe
which is going to be of all I would like
to thank this person for editing this
video there's a lot of other versions
hopefully of this video edited by other
people I encourage you John and also
anyone else to go look at those videos
they still the people who helped me with
this thanks John and I'll see you on
Tuesday bye